Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to give you some
advice, uh, as regards using slang.
Now, my advice upfront is don't try to
learn slang, or at least don't try, don't
try to deliberately learn the slang.
Don't use slang until you are ready.
Slang is difficult.
Uh, it's very easy to grab a hold of
some slang terms and throw them into your
language hoping that they're appropriate.
I'm hoping that it'll create a
great impression, but it's very,
very difficult to pull off.
Now, I know some of you will
immediately say, well, Steve is old.
What does he know?
Uh, young people like to use slang.
Maybe.
But I can tell you that
it's difficult to use.
It's constantly changing.
What's, you know, modern slang today
may be out of fashion by the time you
find that slang term and try to use it.
Um, we, if you spend a lot of time
with people who are using slang and
it becomes sort of very much a part
of your language, then at some point
you will start naturally using it.
If on the other hand you get a dictionary
of slang or a list of popular slang
words in Colombia or in Ecuador or you
know, or in Germany or whatever language
you're learning, and you say, okay, I'm
gonna use those words and that's gonna
make me sound more authentic most of the
time, it won't make you sound authentic.
It'll make, it'll somehow
to the native speaker comes
across, comes across as strange.
In other words, there is a point in
our use of language where we naturally
start to use words that we have heard,
and we have heard them so often that
we know exactly what they mean and
we know exactly how they're used.
Now, the same can be said for other words,
until you've heard particular words or
phrases often enough, you're not totally
confident that you can use them correctly.
All of that is true, but it's a bigger
issue with slang because with slang we're
almost saying, you know, I'm totally
cool and up on the latest of slang, and
you sort of present yourself as someone
who naturally uses these slang terms.
But if you aren't in fact a person who
naturally uses those slang terms, then
the impression created is often negative.
You may get some laughs, but it
doesn't give the impression that you
are a competent user of the language.
And by slang, I, I, you know, refer
to sort of terms, uh, you know,
terms, you know, "Hey dude", you
can say, dude, but if you don't
feel totally comfortable calling
someone, dude, don't call them dude.
Uh, comes a point...
there will be a point where you're
comfortable using that term, but until
then, and it'll come out naturally.
It's like so much in language
learning, even, you know,
polite language in, in Japanese.
I don't make a deliberate attempt to
learn polite forms so that at some point
I'm gonna trot out this polite form.
I sort of speak a neutral form of the
language, and at some point I will have
heard these polite terms so often that
it'll just be natural for me to use the
more polite form in a certain situation.
However, most of the time, if I use the
sort of a neutral form of the language
that works, nobody in Japan is ever
offended if you use the literal form.
However, if you use a too familiar,
slangy form of the language with someone
who is not, say, if you are in group,
that can create a bit of a wincing, uh,
on the part of the person who hears it.
Whereas if you stay with neutral
language, you can't go wrong.
Now, as with so many things in
language, it depends on the language
environment that you are a part of.
It's a bit like this, you know,
deliberately learning, you know,
business English or academic English.
Uh, slang in many ways is more difficult
than business English or academic English.
You have to have a very, you know,
strong sense of the sort of sensitivity
of when to use certain slang words and
when not, or even certain abbreviations.
There's a tendency because you hear, I'm
gonna wanna you exaggerate gonna  wanna.
You think the thing to say is, I'm gonna
do this, I'm gonna, I wanna do this.
I say, I wanna, I'm
gonna, I say it naturally.
I don't deliberately say I, I mean
I try, I think I'm saying I'm going
to, but I end up saying I'm gonna,
or I wanna, instead of I want to.
But the learner should train him
or herself to say, I want to, I'm
going to, and gradually over time
it'll become, I'm gonna wanna to.
You know, in French, for example ... but
after a while you start naturally saying
... but at least in your mind you're
saying ... you're trying to stay with
a sort of neutral form of the language.
And naturally certain slang expressions,
certain contractions, certain forms
of the language will creep into
your language because you've heard
it so often and you're sort of,
you know, instinctively using those
forms, in which case it's fine.
But if you deliberately say, boy,
you know, the really cool French
people, they don't say ... they say
...
so I'm gonna say ... it'll,
it'll sound funny.
It won't work.
All of this is of course even
more true with swear words.
Swear words are difficult to use.
Be very careful.
Make sure you're comfortable with how
these words are used, who will appreciate
you using them, and probably your
best advice to stay away from them.
Uh, and I was referring by the way to
business English or academic English.
Those are again, forms of the language
where because you are, are in an
environment which is say business.
So business Japanese, I spent, you
know, most of my Japanese language
interactions while living in Japan were
with business people and specifically
relating to the wood business.
So I became very familiar with
terms and in fact a lot of the
customers were from the Kansai.
So all kinds of, sort of,
in other words, Osaka area.
Um, you know, expressions,
intonations naturally became a
part of how I speak Japanese.
I don't, I didn't deliberately go out
to try and sound more like someone from
Osaka, but people have told me that there
are times when my, uh, Japanese seems
to reflect a certain Kansai influence.
It happens naturally.
So I think we want to allow our
language to develop naturally
based on who we're talking to, what
subject matter we're dealing with
and not to try to deliberately learn,
you know, slang or swear words.
Uh, or as I say, you know, business
Japanese, business French, business.
If you are with people enough, if you
read enough material, if you listen
to enough material, uh, which has a
certain form of the language, you will
naturally start to speak that way.
And so I would advise people to place
the emphasis on acquiring different
ways of speaking naturally by putting
yourself in situations where you're
hearing that form of a language a lot.
And to avoid deliberately trying to
impress people with, uh, slang or
your interpretation of how people are
speaking that you think are very cool
and you would like to be like them,
rather let the process happen naturally.
Now, I hope that doesn't sound
too much like an old fuddy duddy,
like, uh, fuddy duddy is probably
a slang, a very outdated slang.
Maybe now the equivalent would
be boomer or some such term.
At any rate that those
are my views on slang.
I hope that was helpful and I'll
leave you a couple of videos that
talk about using different forms of
the language in different situations.
Thank you for listening.